what makes GSB so good at takedowns I've
got a chance to even recently watch him
do take Downs within this framework that
you you're teaching what stands out to
you about him that you draw lessons from
yeah that's uh another example of
someone who's performing takedowns in a
rule set radically different from
wrestling
um just as the ADCC rule set is so
different from conventional wrestling
rule sets that the whole manner which
you approach takedowns and even your
understanding of takedowns has to be
quite strongly modified so to an MMA
it's even more extreme
um people always think oh this guy's a
good wrestler he should be able to get
takedowns in MMA easily
what you find is that the wrestling
skills in MMA enable you to finish
takedowns if you get in on your opponent
and get through the legs or the waist or
what have you your wrestling skill will
enable you to finish the takedown but
getting to the takedown is
massively different in the context of
MMA than it is in wrestling the entire
stance is different
foreign
distancing is different there's the idea
of positioning within a cage like how
close you are to the the perimeter of
the of the cage changes radically how
you approach the takedown
um the setups are literally night and
day different it's the setups are almost
entirely comprised composed of striking
setups rather than grappling setups
and so the act of getting to the
takedown
is like a completely different sport now
George studied wrestling
and I used to go to wrestling practice
twice a week in Canada they do Freestyle
Wrestling they don't use the American
college style of wrestling now George's
main emphasis in wrestling training was
takedowns obviously the whole ground
element of of Freestyle Wrestling was no
interest to him like learning how to put
people's back on the ground and turn
them with leg laces and gut wrenches was
of no value in MMA so he devoted almost
all of his study to just the act of
taking someone down
um so as in pure wrestling George is not
bad
um uh I think he would be a very
competitive match even for a highly
ranked uh American freestyle wrestler if
she he would lose easily on the ground
because he's not used to the part here
he'd probably be legalized or gut
wrenched quite easily by a skilled
opponent but in just a pure takedown
battle he'd be a competitive training
partner for even a good wrestler but in
actual MMA competition he could take
down even the most highly credentialed
wrestlers and in some cases it'll make
it look almost effortless
um
and that
came from his unification of striking
skill with wrestling so he used
wrestling skills to finish the takedown
and his karate and uh boxing kickboxing
pedigree to enter into the takedown
now when he initiated the study of this
this was at a time when MMA was pretty
much in its infancy and uh
uh he was one of the
most impressive people I've ever seen in
this regard he was a true innovator he
innovated this specialized area of
striking to a takedown to a greater
degree than anyone else I'm aware of
okay well let me ask you about this
Innovation because you're one of the
most Innovative people in in uh martial
arts
there's several major categories of
innovation that you have led
um obviously leg locks
body lock
now wrestling
what's your process of innovation so
seeing
the problems in a particular system the
the gaps
how do you identify them and how do you
figure out systems of how to fill those
gaps first thing I look for is
what are the current weaknesses in a
given
combat sport so in the case of
Jiu Jitsu it was very obvious that
historically Judas had always been weak
and leg locking you just had always been
weak in a standing position overall and
um
these were things that needed to be
sorted out immediately and its infancy
mixed martial arts was divided between
Grapplers and strikeless Strikers and
uh most of the uh emphasis in early
mixed martial arts was on the idea of
specialists in a given domain forcing
the fight into their domain
and that
uh my early work with George Saint
Pierre convinced me that the right
approach wasn't increased specialization
and learning to force
uh your athlete into that area of
specialization at the expense of the
opponent but rather the the real battles
of the future would be won and lost not
worth
techniques per se specialized techniques
but rather the integration of techniques
and the overlap between the various
grappling and striking skills
so that someone who was an inferior uh
uh Grappler would have just enough
grappling skills to be able to hold a
Grappler off and then defeat them with
uh striking and a striker who was uh if
you've went to fight a someone who's
Superior to you and striking you would
have just enough striking skill to be
able to hold them at Bay and then enter
into grappling this went further and
further until it got clear that there
were whole areas of the sport that
needed you need to change your entire
mindset about them
um
so that people went into
early MMA thinking in terms of Grappler
and Striker
um what I started to think is in terms
of okay there are four fundamental skill
areas of mixed martial arts there is
shoot boxing which is the integration of
uh
takedowns and and striking there is
clinch boxing which is the integration
of upper body clinch skills combined
with striking there is fence boxing
which the two athletes are locked up
with each other on the fence
um uh and they have to integrate take
down take down defense and striking
skills and there is grapple boxing which
is the merging of ground grappling with
striking and when you broke MMA down
into those four categories you saw that
each one of those four domains
transcends
the specialized martial arts that form
their components so for example in in
clinch boxing you would incorporate
things from Judo Greco-Roman freestyle
uh Jiu-Jitsu submissions Muay Thai
clinching techniques
but
even if you took all five of those
the rule set that you're operating in
required such extensive modification
that the final product of clinch boxing
transcended all five of its component
martial arts and became its own
autonomous skill needed to be worked
autonomously and when we broke
Georgia's training down into those four
areas that's when real progress started
to be made that's when you started to
see the integration of those four phases
and the Striking and grappling within
each of them
was where victory was being won and and
lost so once you reframe how you see a
particular combat sport
then you can start doing these detailed
development of ideas
that actually like they they fit there's
a sense in which that it had to start
with a paradigm shift and then a
research program began after that you
don't start with research you start with
the paradigm shift and then went to
research